Es passierte während einer Debatte über
den Brexit im britischen Unterhaus in London:
Der konservative Politiker Ken Clarke hielt
am Dienstag gerade eine längere Rede über
die möglichen Auswirkungen des britischen
Austritts aus der EU.
Sein Parteikollege Desmond Swayne konnte dem
aber offenbar nicht so richtig folgen.
Auf den Bildern des Parlamentsfernsehens ist
zu sehen, wie Swayne im Rücken des Redners zur Seite kippt.
Es sieht so aus, als ob der Politiker schlafen
würde.
Als der Redner lauter wird, schreckt Swayne
kurz auf.
Um dann scheinbar wieder einzunicken.
Schließlich kommt der schläfrige Abgeordnete
dann aber doch zur Besinnung.
Und das mit einem Lächeln auf den Lippen.